bienvenue dans paf pas vous le savez ce
sont des débats sur des thèmes
d'actualité avec un invité aujourd'hui
jean michel fourgous bonjour bonjour
vous êtes maire d'elancourt de vice
président de la communauté de libration
ancien député proche de nicolas sarkozy
je dois bien dire donc on a beaucoup de
sujets avis va aborder avec vous un
invité et puis et puis une bombe en
france par véronique et turbines
bonjourbonjour touristes notamment
versailles plus voilà tout va bien tout
va très très bien
nouveau est sortie aujourd'hui de
nouveau nous versailles plus difficile
on est virtuel tous les mois tous les
mois
non non non c'est plus sérieux et les
voilà tous les maux remercie évoluer le
beau geste ou les dents très bien
jean-luc babec bonjour bonjour vous êtes
vraiment vous êtes aussi un des
responsables du groupement national des
indépendants qui va voir le jour
ça y est c'est en ville on est donc les
tous les syndicats représentant les
entreprises indépendants de notre
secteur ont signé un accord les statuts
là dans quatre jours maintenant et c'est
en route ça va représenter quand même
vingt mille entreprises hôteliers
restaurateurs cafetiers brasseur
discothèques traiteurs s'échouer dans un
grand groupe comme le plus bruyant il
dans notre secteur
concernant les entreprises indépendantes
très bien mustapha allaoui bonjour
bonjour ça va
ça va vous êtes étudiant de votre bat un
des derniers brillamment on va dire à et
et alors on va voir dans certains films
oui déjà il ya eu deux tête-à-tête avec
une harpiste cécile corbel jean claude
vannier et puis dans quelques jours
tadic est un compositeur oui l'arrangeur
de décompte connaissent peut être pas
assez et et raphaël enthoven aussi dans
quelques jours donc attendre présente
bien et jean charles lajoie dit bonjour
bonjour vous êtes éditeur et vous voilà
on va dire que ça que tous les quinze
jours nous amener un nouvel un nouvel
nouveau chef-d'oeuvre nouveau
chef-d'oeuvre celui versé de yann
thirion ça s'appelle 20 manière de se
débarrasser des limaces alors j'ai pas
lu encore nous donner
c'est donc aux éditions la joie ni et en
plus vous appelez lajoinie donc tout va
bien c'était plus simple le plus simple
alors je vous propose de commencer à
dire est-ce que vous avez regardé le
match du psg jean-michel naud
malheureusement non vous aimez pas le
foot foot si mes joueurs et dans une
manifestation mondiale lorsque la france
est symbolisée par l alarme serait nommé
mail à la norme et en est venu à bout
c'est qu'on a dit on a des horaires qui
sont un peu particulier les politiques
mais bon on oublie de la souffrance
non mais ça y est le football sarkozy
oui sarkozy
oui je sais mais ouais mais oui là il
est pas encore il est pas encore mais ça
arrange luxe et il est pas encore revenu
en politique je veux que je ne
m'intéresse pas beaucoup au sport en
général mais surtout quand et des
grandes compétitions cet été la coupe du
monde évidemment
malheureusement j'ai été un peu déçue
mais j'adore surtout quand on est
footballeur parle et je suis très
reconnaissante
non je suis désolé c'est pas méchant
francky merci sa petite expression la
roue tourne à tourner je m'en sers tous
les jours et j'adore non mais
franchement c'est trop mignon
et deuxième chose j'adore aussi la jeune
entendu à la radio hier lilian thuram
qui a une
association qui lutte contre le racisme
par l'éducation et qui aussi et parents
d'une autre association qui s'appelle
demos qui fait écouter de la musique
classique et qui fait jouer des enfants
de tous milieux dans les écoles et je
trouve ça génial donc merci le foot
jean-luc madec je peux pas m'intéresser
à tous donc le football j'ai abandonné
moi je pensais vraiment qu'on vient de
citer permettre de poule
la question est posée oui battant si
vous avez envie et je ne m'étais pas ce
serait une première
je n'ai pas regardé manas dans très
sincèrement je n'ai pas pu alors c'était
c'était une journée un peu particulière
pour la profession aussi et donc c'était
donc j'ai fait grève de tv également
voilà donc j'ai pas vu de match
cela étant cela étant c'est une
information majeure pour le foot
moi je le dis parce que effectivement
sur le papier c'était pas gagné on en
face de nous un barça conquérant on a on
a mis des moyens colossaux sur une
équipe on est quand même en champion s
league
voilà donc les rockingham 1,8 g salée
face à l'efes à l'effet vrai mais bien
sûr ils avaient tous devenir des vers a
tiré sa des faits rêver comme ceux qui
font du cinéma du théâtre et regard du
festival de cannes qui rêve à travers
les stars
donc eu principalement salle et ferrer
mais bien sûr bien sûr j'étais passionné
ça pour rien au monde
c'était magnifique aussi quoi qu'il se
passe pas de grève et avoir des
principes ce en étant d'avoir un
principe je ne je ne dérange pas cette
faille dans le foot c'était un match
extraordinaire magnifique une leçon de
football des deux côtés pas par moments
des joueurs extraordinaires
ddd minutes qui duraient des heures à la
fin parce que j'étais terrorisée à
l'idée qu'ils avaient gagné c'est en
face de s'imposer le côté face un match
magnifique
un match magnifique alors on va parler
on parle de sexualité dire la fin de
l'émission parce qu'il paraît que c'est
la débandade les gens ne font plus
l'amour de font de moins en moins la
boue pour trois raisons parce qu'ils
sont stressés par le par le boulot
évidemment parce que voilà c'est tout ça
les stresse mais aussi souvent parce
qu'ils ont à des animaux de compagnie et
que quand vous avez quand le chien d'or
sur le lit c'est moins facile de faire
des galipettes non sexuellement je sais
pas mais mon avis ils ont tout ce qu'il
faut pour planter des gunners toujours
vous de vos là elles sont toutes canon
et fait du sport
maintenant quand l'équipe première joue
vous vous exiger qu'il n'y a pas de
rapport sexuel justement la veille
on exige absolument rien à ce niveau-là
information n'a pas de nom vous donnez
pas bien il n'y a pas de produit qui
soit dans qu'ils soient des stimulants
avant ou après match maintenant ils ont
une totale liberté au niveau où on est
aujourd'hui on rentre pas jusque dans la
chambre à coucher pour le moment très
bien alors on va aborder un certain
nombre de sujets d'abord on va commencer
par des sujets qui intéressent les
yvelines d'abord un sujet qui intéresse
elancourt c'est cette fameuse piste de
ski alors j'ai l'impression tout le
monde est favorable à cette piste de ski
chez vous moi ça me paraît
c'est aberrant dans l'univers du ski a
eu beaucoup mais bon on va en parler de
quelques instants je vais d'abord
peut-être un petit sujet parce que quand
je dis tout le monde est d'accord c'est
pas vrai il y en a qui proteste le 320
mètres de descente pour skieurs et
snowboardeurs abrité sous un complexe de
22 mille mètres carrés sur le sommet de
la colline d'elancourt est maintenu à
une température de moins cinq degrés
toute l'année
une image qui fait froid dans le dos
pour les écologistes et une partie des
riverains venus en nombre pour cette
première réunion publique de
concertation organisée en mairie le 3
juillet n'a rien à faire ici cette piste
de ski ici y'a pas de neige à rien il
est préférable de végétaliser et puis de
faire des promenades enfants enfin
famille c'est certainement plus
intéressant que de faire un ski dont 20
qui va des naturalisés le site est elle
à vue dont il était ridicule
c'est un projet privé qui va ramener des
capitaux pour du privé avec des
subventions publiques
et si le projet ne fonctionne pas ça
redeviendra une charge pour le public
c'est à dire pour les impôts des
citoyens représentants de la ville et de
la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines souhaitait
simplement présenté à la population la
procédure de révision du plu le plan
local de l'urbanisme qui doit permettre
de rendre le site constructibles ils ont
également été obligés de s'expliquer sur
leurs intentions
pour l'instant le projet n'est pas
validé il devra être examiné par les
élus de la majorité gmail en cours mais
aussi par les deux groupes
les trois groupes d'opposition de la
commune ils seront consultés nous les
écouterons et après si le projet est
validé à l'ensemble des élus à la fois
d'elancourt et de la communauté
d'agglomération
bien évidemment il y aura une réunion de
concertation où là on rentrera dans les
aspects techniques du projet les
principaux acteurs locaux du dossier
s'ils soutiennent l'idée d'un ski dôme
assure que cela ne se fera pas son de
nombreuses garanties en termes
d'environnement mais aussi financières
la société small world qui développera
le ski dom comme elle l'a déjà fait aux
pays-bas attend quant à elle un
investissement de taille avant de
s'installer infrastructures de transport
et de déplacement notamment 500 places
de parking serait nécessaire
avant que le projet ne devienne réalité
après avoir été lancé pour la première
fois voici 20 ans d'autres réunions
publiques sont déjà annoncées pour la
rentrée
si les plus optimistes parlent d'une
ouverture en 2017 les canons à neige
artificielle ne sont pas encore prêts à
être déployés
jean michel fourgous à la rosette de
maire d'elancourt c'est sur votre corps
humain alors d'abord ça fait 30 ans
qu'on a un espace qu un bel espace c'est
la colline est plus élevée d'île de
france
ça fait 30 ans qu'on cherche un projet
aussi bien en arabe aux droits oui il ya
une dizaine d'années ces dernies nos
collègues de gauche qui dirigeait la
castille qui ont lancé ce projet vont se
regarder ça au début gros et puis on a
on a analysé on a aussi on s'est
concerté avec beaucoup d'élan courtois
dernier une majorité de l'emporter
inquiet pour comprendre ce qui peut être
fait par nos élèves de carnot minori par
nos minorités activistes ccc c'est bon
c'est le jeu ah bon donc voilà alors
c'est donc ce alors vous avez une
colline alors vous vous faites quoi
c'est vrai qu'une colline bon vous allez
faire des sports de glisse si vous
voulez trouver un investissement
significatif si vous voulez bon c'est un
sport de glisse saurait pas faire un
truc je ne suis pas sous marin bon voilà
donc bien entendu c'est ce sport là qui
est le plus adapté deuxièmement on a vu
à lyon que les gens qui sont de les
spécialistes ils nous ont tous dit ça
aussi bon goût d'un membre alors il ya
un projet snowboard qui comme un d un
des leaders mondiaux de ce genre de
projet on a beaucoup travaillé que on a
amendé on les a embêtés sûr
sur sur tout et sur tous les éléments
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que c'est un
projet qui est quand même une saine
maturité
alors on voit arriver n'osait nono de
nos amis écologistes bon alors d'abord
le riz montrent une association qui
s'appelle les amis de la colline de la
revanche d'abord falloir dire que ça
n'existe plus la veine de la revanche a
été rebaptisé s'appelle la colline
d'elancourt un bon c'est pas grave on
alors les a mises et le pilote de cette
opération ils habitent même pas ils
encourent il ya une autre ville bon
alors pourquoi pas mais mais mais bon
c'est mignon ça mais bon moi je suis
amené à un ennemi de la colline je veux
dire je fais pas partie de cette
association je suis un avis dehors de la
colline d'elancourt et non pas la
revanche qui est pas non plus très
positif et non le bon bref
et alors au début ils étaient une
dizaine et une vingtaine alors
maintenant il ya d'autres fois je les ai
vus dans une fête il passait il ya même
les parents qui le démarque écouter ce
qu'on peut arrêter de faire signer mais
monfils à 14 ans je vais lui faire
signer une pétition il n'a rien compris
on ne raconte que c'est de bien contre
le mal le vrai contre le faux bolobo
contrôler quand même bon bref c'est fois
de sérieux alors on nous dit qu'on va
réchauffer la planète
on va réchauffer la planète mais voyons
les effectivement vous avez vous avez
des conditions de l'offre ici d'air etc
mais on n'est pas plus que pas plus que
jusqu'à 12 mai mais en plus c'est
beaucoup plus moderne que que même
certaines patinoires deuxième on nous
dit que c'est un truc pour les riches
bon bah comme d'habitude un vieux truc
en france non c'est pas trop riche pour
aller aux sports d'hiver
aujourd'hui vous passez une journée soit
dire c'est 100 euros pour un repas par
personne et avec tous si vous faites la
mine c'est bon là ce sera 20 30 euros
dont arrêtons de dire que c'est
uniquement prochain au contraire ya des
gens ne trouveront pas la valise arc qui
pourront venir faire un arrêté pour les
pour le vendre et c'est pas pour les
peaux mais c'est pour des chariots des
moyens
troisièmement on nous dit qu'est ce
qu'on nous dit palais on nous dit oui ça
va bouffer tout la grille nexter pas du
tout ça fait 22 mm kaboul avait répété
la colline il fait 520 mille mètres
carrés 40 52 ha c'est environ 500 ml bon
vrai que ça fait 5 % cette piste elle va
faire cinq ans soit les mettons 20% avec
les aménagements tout donc mais vous
avez 80% on va faire un parc famille à
parc floral des décidé d'aider chemin et
elle se rend enfin valoriser avec
tellement il ya 100 personnes sur 30000
habitants quasiment d'elancourt y a que
100 personnes quand profit de personnes
y va c'est utilisé pour les décharges
sauvages pour les gens du voyage pour
pour pour les motos qui bien sûr casse
complètement la colline l'abîmé et ses
fonds à un barreau fois possible et
voisins peu plus donc voilà on va au
bout de 30 ans on va enfin proposer
quelque chose de constructif de hbo qui
va permettre en plus de enfin faire pour
80 % du reste quelque chose de
totalement public accessible à tout le
monde pour pour les 1 b un joli parc
famille donc c'est un beau projet en
plus il s'équilibre puisque c'est le
privé alors contrairement à ce qu'on est
dans un jeu opposant ce qu'il dit c'est
scandaleux c'est le grand capital on
arrête on c'est insupportable qu en
france on ose encore prononcé le mot
grand capital mars il est mort en 1996
il a même pas connu la cgt des
industries et la société de services
numériques des virements de bois de
branches alors donc en soyons sérieux
c'est un beau projet maintenant il peut
aussi être abordée voilà il peut et doit
il doit être sans cesse mais bien sûr
améliorer mais c'est un beau projet on
peut pas comme ça et il ya un sondage
abc qui fit ce qui est favorable
question vous dit qu'il fallait
absolument faire quelque chose on peut
pas laisser une colline tels qu'ils
étaient obligés de faire quelque chose
c'est ma première question s'il ya
beaucoup d'endroits en france a
heureusement et les collines et on
n'imagine pas d'y construire quoi que ce
soit ça c'est là de la première chose
pourrait juste faire un endroit je lis
avec des arbres de la pelouse c est ce
qu on est obligé toujours de bétonner de
bon voisinage j'ai rien contre le ski
pour les gens qui auront pas là de quoi
est ce qu'il y à val d'isère ça c'est
plutôt une bonne idée mais on pouvait
aussi faire un remonte-pente avec du vtt
il ya plein de choses et qu'on vous dit
que ça va être beau j'ai quelques doutes
sur le fait que dans un dôme puisse être
absolument magnifique voilà c'est un peu
c'est très dévalorisée actuellement
c'est un site très dévalorisée accent il
fallait à moins d'un pour cent des
siennes en compte qu'il utilise donc
demain il n'y a plus d'un pour cent des
élans pour toi qui vont utiliser ce site
c'est quand même c'est quand même le but
mais c'est un peu comme si vous disiez
on a une forêt de 50 hectares mais
finalement on va en faire quelque chose
mais on peut laisser une forêt de 50
hectares je trouve que le débat est
intéressant pour ma part j'ai passé une
bonne partie de ma vie au coeur de
l'économie du loisir de les colonnes de
mozilla j'ai juste vous parlez un peu
d'histoire
le premier gouvernement sous françois
mitterrand était le gouvernement mauroy
et rappelez-vous que andré henry okah
l'ip et le ministère du temps libre
alors j'ai été moi dans ce maelström
pendant une bonne dizaine d'années et
j'ai été un des concepteurs puis le
premier patron de l'aquaboulevard dans
le 15e arrondissement et j'ai monté
également des parcs aquatiques ou verts
urbains en province
donc j'ai été au bilieux de l'économie
du loisir pendant une bonne partie de
mon existence
qu'est-ce que ça m'a appris eh bien ça
m'a appris que effectivement la
politique à l'époque volontariste de
françois mitterrand dans la présentation
de porter son voile était de dire on va
donner aux français du temps et de
l'argent
pas de pot ils ont eu du temps et pas
d'argent
du coup les schtroumpfs landes l'émirat
police zhiguo folie's et et autres parcs
de même nature se sont écroulés
les seuls park qui aujourd'hui ont sorti
leur épingle du jeu mais après des
années d et le père s'appelle disney
astérix a qu'au boulevard qui a réussi à
assen et le futuroscope mais à quel prix
alors moi je dis à jean michel fourgous
que de faire
un site de loisirs sur la colline de la
route sur la collecte des lampes cours
pourquoi alors pourquoi pas mais il faut
avoir une approche réaliste de et
l'environnement économique du domaine du
loisir en france et croyez moi c'est
difficile déjà dans d'autres domaines
d'activité qui quand même lié aux
loisirs la restauration c'est pas très
facile donc moi je demande simplement
pour être prudent à l'égard de la
dépense des deniers publics de regarder
quand même avec attention ce qu'il y a
lieu en ce moment d'étudier dans le
domaine du loisir avec son environnement
économique et ce qui se passera dans les
décennies à venir parce que j'imagine
que jean michel fourgous ce n'est pas un
dogme pour cinq ans que s'il fait ce
projet c'est pour l'avenir de la ville
nouvelle et il faut y faire très
attention
voilà là dessus mais heureusement les
gens n'ont plus d'argent pour aller au
ski ils vont tous rappliquer sur votre
collines et ça va faire le bonheur de
plein d'enfants et voilà c'est génial
mais bien sûr on va l'acquérir écoute
dire une école mais aussi pour les
jeunes les benjamins donc ils pourront
dire est ce que ma deux mondes excusez
moi ils pourront passer même une journée
deux ou trois jours selon lui rien et
dire j'ai eu ma première étoile moi
aussi simplement ça s'est un peu moqué
de dubaï pour dubaï a pas de sauf que
dubaï dubai sauf que dubaï c'est pour
quelque sorte que dubaï c'est pour
quelques semaines est réellement
population quand je jouais au foot
régulièrement pendant des années alors
que là on a quand même un business model
qui tient au regard au regard de la
population si on regarde la
démocratisation mais pourrait par
l'agenge à l'époque des faits de fergus
on n'est pas obligé vers la colline
il n'y a pas de neige non plus
probablement colis grand chose
non jean-charles la résistance à jean
charles a raison mais le regard des
enfants qui sont désoeuvrés pendant les
vacances je pense que ça n'a pas de prix
on cite ou jean charles a raison sur un
point on n'est pas obligé de toucher à
la colline on n'est pas obligé en
revanche ans
en revanche on a peut-être l'obligation
non pas de toucher ou ne pas toucher
moins dans l'obligation de faire quelque
chose pour tout ce qui touche quand même
à l'emploi je crois que c'est quand même
d'une domaine des politiques c'est du
domaine de encore une fois de tous ceux
qui encadrent l'économie de faire
quelque chose mais je trouve que si on
peut mixer les deux avec toutes les
précautions que vient d'en donner notre
ami jean luc c'est vrai qu'il ya des
précautions à prendre
ce qui était bien le reportage quand on
dit qu'on va encore mettre des deniers
publics dans cette affaire mais on en
met partout des deniers publics moi je
suis sponsorisé à 100% donc le foot
culturellement ça passe je serai à 100%
j'ai pas un centime du privé qui
sponsorise le foot et c'est pour bien
évidemment des gens qui n'ont pas
forcément les moyens
demain ça serait drôle ce qui suit on
mettrait des deniers publics ça me
choquerait pas à partir avant il ya une
vraie rentabilité du site il ya un vrai
accueil du public
il ya une vraie volonté de faire en
sorte que moi j'étais animateur socio
culturel pendant des années donc je n'ai
pas eu la capacité de fonder des choses
comme toi mais j'étais au plus près des
des gamins dans les cités ça coûte
beaucoup plus cher aux municipalités d
emmener à la montagne au ski si
éventuellement pour leur proposer
quelque chose avec une rentabilité
meilleure ce serait de rentabilité pour
les communes et ça favoriserait aussi a
pas forcément les pauvres et puis encore
une fois si on pouvait toucher - la
montagne
moi je trouve c'est parfait pour le ski
de montagne préserver l et mettez tout à
elancourt
dimitri un mot désagréable et les autres
dates actions qu'il ya dans le coin je
vis en france miniature il manquait une
base de loisirs aussi à 50 ans ex
ordinaire qui aurait tout un se
développerait de tourisme de 50 ans nos
errances voilà donc tous nous autorise
pas
si un skate park à l encre ans oui bon
donc on voit que le dossier quand même
pas totalement bouclé pire souvenir
qu'on est en train de construire
quand même un espace d'excellence 50 ans
au grand saint quentin qui va être
élargie et on veut effectivement qui est
une origine est et une qualité de vie et
enfin il ya des beaux produits vous en
avez rappelé un certain nombre on veut
vraiment on a vécu les plus belles
entreprises les les
les très bons ingénieurs des très bons
techniciens très bon jour il aidé des
ensembles de loisirs de très bon niveau
donc vraiment si on veut ressembler à
une silicon valley à la française comme
on souhaite avec le grand saint quentin
oui il faut il faut qu'à une cohérence
de ces de ses activités de loisirs et
vous avez toute la panoplie avec cela
vous donne donc c'est assez exceptionnel
en france d'avoir aidé une série
d'activités sportives ludiques comme
cela mais je vous parle même pas de la
pédagogie puisque vous savez que tout 55
ans est une des rares zones en très haut
débit dont bien sûr il ya de la
modernité wii et de la modernité ou
alors si on est contre la modernité où
il faut il faut peut-être aller dans le
danger pas dans l'aveyron très bien mais
c'est très bien la veyron exploit qu'à
nous mêmes mais c'est vrai que c'est une
zone d'excellence dénigrer la transition
vers logique et adapte pas le moment
d'aller faire des de la neige on
attendait ça réchauffe
jusque là il faut fermer les palais les
bâtiments art il faut fermer un paquet
une entreprise parce que
les activités mais se sait rien en terme
d'électricité enfin c'est un argument en
liquide qui est affectif mais faut être
sérieux c'est pas plus c'est pas plus ça
bouge pas plus qu'il n'est qu'une simple
même mois puisque les machineries sont
plus modernes que les lits patinoire qui
sont bon voilà alors mardi est ce que
vous avez respirer parce qu'il ya eu un
combat de titans larcher qu'on devrait
raffarin un taux l'afrique pour la
présidence du sénat tout le monde était
toute la france était comme ça ça serait
plus là
qui va gagner est ce que ça va être la
richesse que ça mettra fin ça a été
finalement larcher on dit que c'est à
dire c'est une c'est une défaite de
sarkozy on va en parler dans quelques
instants
est-ce que pourquoi les gens se
désintéressent autour du sénat et ce
qu'ils ont raison de le faire dans les
crises on est dans une crise et je vous
rappelle qu'on n'est que le début
vous êtes sur un bateau à force 5 pour
le vent et vous allez pas savoir ce vide
dans quelques mois donc il faut bien
intégrer la un bon alors larcher c'est
un type qui a une compétence qui
reconnut il a été président je crois
qu'il connaît bien le réseau sûr c'est
aussi pour ça qu'il a gagné connais très
bien la zone et c'est à dire je crois
pas que sarkozy lit je crois pas sarouel
moi ça m'arrangerait bien sûr je suis
proche de lui les communes d'à côté
quasiment on est très amis mais cela dit
au delà de ça
vous allez rentrer dans une phase
difficile l'arche indiscutable on a
quelqu'un qui a un très gros réseau qui
sait être un peu un amortissement aussi
je vais je vais me projeter un peu
excusez-moi admettons on dit beaucoup
que sarkozy estimant fortes chances bien
sûr de rejoindre rôle important demain
mais mais c'est vrai que lui s'éteint
c'est un attaquant c'est comme en
football ça n'attaque ansar positivement
le célèbre larcher et plus je ne joue
pas sur son besoin sur son confort mais
il amortit joueur si jamais observée
donc je dirais il faut des équipes assez
complémentaires et ne ressemble pas à
sarkozy mais sa reprise n'a pas donné de
consigne de vote
contrairement à ce qui est dit n'a pas
donné de consigne de vote sarkozy pour
l'un ou pour l'autre à fareins et ça ça
c'est ce que certains de ses
collaborateurs pour jouer ou rejouer en
com mais voilà priori sarkozy s'est pas
mêlé de cette élection mais bon je dis
ce qu'ils veulent dire ça voilà je passe
l'information de cas au delà de ça le
sénat on en parle beaucoup aujourd'hui
parce que c'est vrai que ces élections
sénatoriales on reparle de la
suppression du sénat parce que c'est une
chambre qui ne représente plus qu une
france rurale qui est la france du début
du xxème siècle qui n'est donc plus
démocratique
je me souvenais des débats de maurice
duverger tour de gaule qui parlait déjà
de la suppression du sénat est ce que
c'est une chambre utile ou pas peut-être
ont fait un petit tour de table et en
salle moi c'est la politique moi je
trouve c'est indispensable que d'abord
vous vous dites pas méchamment vcc lune
le sénat c'est le la france rurale avec
c'était un bel arrêt la france rurale
elle existe heureusement et voilà
heureusement qu'il ya des gens et la
france n'est pas que dans lieu non plus
donc on peut aussi considérer que
l'expression de gens qui habitent dans
des zones qui ne sont pas des zones
dites à risque c'est de la première
chose et puis deuxièmement tout le monde
enfin beaucoup de gens disent que le
sénat ne sert pas à grand chose ça donne
un recul ce bicamérisme qui est très
intéressant parce que l'assemblée peut
décider de choses qui sont rediscutés au
sénat même si de toute façon l'assemblée
nationale a le dernier mot mais ça donne
du recul et solène delà de la
possibilité de discussions dans ce sens
là c'est absolument indispensable sinon
le l'assemblée nationale la pourrait
voter n'importe quoi la vie politique
s'accélérant de plus en plus on est
passé au quinquennat la vie politique
s'accélère de plus en plus avec les
médias avec on voit bien qu'une phrase
qui dit aujourd'hui reproduite à
l'infini à vitesse grand v
c'est vrai qu'on a là une chambre allait
même le mot chambre déjà parler d'elle
même c'est un peu plus assoupi c'est
donc moins c'est un peu plus lent et
donc ça ça amorti la seule chose que moi
que je que j'aurai envie le souhait que
devrait formuler ce serait que les deux
chambres soit toujours du même bord
parce que je trouve qu'on est clivant en
permanence on a parlé de la piste de ski
à elancourt globalement je suis pas
percé peut-être que je me trompe ce le
maire mais c'était peut-être
probablement des gens de l'opposition
côté ce jour là pour dire qu'on est
contre parce qu'en fait ils sont contre
112 de droite alors qu'ils sont de
gauche et donc quand on est de droite ou
de gauche on est d'accord pour une piste
de ski ou pas c'est un peu un peu
aberrant et là pour le coup ça freine un
peu ce qui s'avère plus que ça ça
dépasse les clivages a amorti
enfin les échos les clés pour dix
derniers mois c'était la gauche pousser
ce projet quand c'est la drogue qui
pousse ce projet web alors dont voilà
donc je me dis que finalement ça serait
bien mais c'est qu'un voeu c'est pas
possible et une démocratie il ya un vote
mais c'est vrai que ont ralenti en
permanence les choses en france par ce
problème les habitations du même
et justement c'est une manière de dire
on prend du recul au sénat mais on est
du même bord d'ailleurs au gouvernement
ils sont au gouvernement et à
l'assemblée nationale ils sont du même
bord et les frontistes et des frontistes
près de quinze jours le senate et
commerçants dans les fennecs dans une
gouvernance sur un pays comme le nôtre
et dans la construction même de la
république et de la constitution il
était près il est préférable d'avoir des
contre pouvoirs au sein même de la
gouvernance nous avons déjà un problème
majeur dans ce pays c'est l'absence de
représentativité réelle du peuple
français
c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
il vote exerçables de plus en plus
souvent et c'est bien dangereux mais là
évidemment que le fait qu'il y ait un
contre pouvoir au sein même de la
gouvernance ce n'est que justice pour
les gens que la république est censé
représenter ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point sur lequel j'insisterai
c'est un des points sur lesquels
d'ailleurs on entend les commentaires
nous on voit quand même beaucoup de gens
vous savez dans un restaurant et on
parle avec eux c'est que le train de vie
du sénat est bien trop élevée par
rapport à 150 euros par an quand même ça
c'est énorme c'est là aussi où il ya là
plus fort pourcentage le meilleur
ouvrier de france dans les cuisines et
un moment donné il faut quand même
réduire le train de vie de ces gens là
et il devrait donner l'exemple dans un
pays qui aujourd'hui est en grave erreur
le nombre mois de réduire leur train de
vie je vais de la mauricie la litanie de
la rémunération des collaborateurs des
sénateurs
c'est à tomber par terre voilà verdict
s'il y avait un train de vie moins ça
attirerait peut-être moins deux
sénateurs leurs moines sénateurs et
donna au pas dimitri c'est une mauvaise
cuisine amateur le plus jeune finlandais
plus jeunes en quoi c'est françois
baroin il a fait son entrée
dans le plu saison oui ou non cela dit
c'est pas une chose je crois que la
moyenne d'âge est plutôt moins âgé qu
avec l assemblée oui bizarrement fin
contrairement à la réputation mais mais
est ce que je sais pas si les régions
ont un pouvoir plus fort est ce qu'on a
vraiment besoin d'une deuxième chambre
qui était censé à l'origine de
représenter les régions de gaulle vous
êtes vous êtes de l'ump de gaulle
voulait la suppression du sénat au sens
à sa mission avec le conseil économique
et social est ce que ce n'était pas une
bonne solution dans le conseil
économique social vous avez raison ça
franchement on peut se brûler messieurs
faut être sérieux mais d'arrêter trois
chanteurs déjà réduisant celle là deux
des rapports qui dans ce cas ne se sent
jamais lui de telles structures
publiques à réduire mais j'ai une liste
de 102 sans nom je vous l'avais si vous
voulez mettons dans les cabinets 50% de
gens du privé et 50% de gens du public
il faut déjà à sec c'est ça le vrai
problème c'est que demain il faut
remettre dans le processus décisionnel
français les gens qui produisent la
richesse en france les gens qui ont la
solution à l'emploi c'est pas les
fonctionnaires c'est pas les états c'est
pas voilà arrêtons voilà demain c'est
urgent urgent d'en mais même chez les
ministres je vois que dans les mini slap
insolente ministre a créé une entreprise
sans réponse mais dans les cabinets ses
90 % de fonctionnaires seulement 10%
combien tu veux un acte marche enfin
c'est insupportable que la cinquième
puissance mondiale marchand en pleine
guerre mondiale économique parce que la
mondialisation quelque part c'est une
forme comme le gabon avec la victoire
bon là ont plus que jamais on a besoin
des compétences de l'économie réelle
donc partout même dans l'administration
des domaines du boulet khimki qui
modifient qui réforment l'administration
dans les 160 postes importants
administration 50% de ces gens là
doivent au moins 5 ans d'expérience du
privé sinon vous n'aurez pas de réforme
il serait formerons pas parce que ces
réformes aient leur continent leur club
ils le feront pas donc c est demain
l'assemblée nationale ça suffit il faut
que les plus de 50% des
dès lors les députés ou du nom de
députés du nombre de sénateurs quoi pas
mais surtout avant tout la priorité
c'est de remettre de la culture les gens
et bien qu'ils vous font manger que nous
font manger c'est les entrepreneurs faut
arrêter de les chasser comme on les
chasse il faut les réhabiliter un pays
qui met au ban de la société
ces entrepreneurs ses producteurs et de
chasse n'a aucun avenir donc de toutes
façons c'est ces gens là quand la
solution à l'emploi au niveau de vie des
gens à financer les retraites donc ces
gens là ils sont prioritaires il faut il
faut les voilà c'est demain ils doivent
être partout dans le processus
décisionnel français c'est comme ça
qu'on va sauver ce pays qui je vous le
rappelle en en grave difficulté en
danger réel
aujourd'hui l'accord à 600 communes qui
sont en faillite en france c'est que le
début donc ça commence à devenir grave
donc la main et en bruno le maire qui
demande par exemple les fonctionnaires
petit la fonction publique quand ils
sont élus je suis de gauche je l'avais
déjà déposé sa maman à vendre à nous le
maire les suggestions renaud lemaire et
au contraire je suis très content de le
voir dans ce club mais voilà c'est des
gens qui dit où s'est déclenchée
d'entreprise rente la sensation on est
quelques-uns on est on est une
cinquantaine bon on est 130 à peu prêt à
se battre mais il y en a 5 ans devrait
vrai bon on a tout de suite déposé ça
nous voilà le type cantine députés
choisis une bonne fois pour toute ils
s'engagent à des miss est définitivement
la salle de la fonction publique il ya
plein de choses mais les députés l aider
les dans les cabinets ministériels les
hauts fonctionnaires
mais même même dans les universités
là-haut au conseil d'administration de
l'université de saint quentin il faut
50% de gens du privé un type capable cas
pas cas pas cas pas diriger des hommes
dans le site dans l'économie réelle
ccc ccc plus possible aujourd'hui ainsi
plus possible donc là partout 50% la
parité dans toutes françaises
représentées n'est pas que les
entrepreneurs leurs salariés aussi parce
qu'aujourd'hui on parle de lait
s'inscrit dans le style moi je m'en
réjouis
je vous promets que je ne sais pas
comment commis de cuisine mon commis de
salle le coni pâtissiers charcutiers
boulangers il peut aller aujourd'hui de
dépenser son argent qu'il n'a pas donc
jean-michel fourgous a parfaitement
raison il faut une meilleure
représentativité de ceux qui créent les
richesses dans ce pays ça c'est le
premier point puis le deuxième sur
lequel moi j'insiste beaucoup auprès de
nos représentants politiques quel que
soit leur bord c'est de rendre l'argent
aux gens qui bossent
est ce qu'aujourd'hui malheureusement
quand on regarde les salaires que noir
de monde ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
vrai salaire que nous donnons dans nos
entreprises et je parle de mon secteur
d'activité que je connais bien mais dans
l'ensemble des métiers de bouche et
dans l'ensemble des métiers liés à
l'artisanat bâtiments etc
aujourd'hui des salaires que nous
donnons sont des salaires qui sont
inadaptées aux efforts réels que nous
demandons à nos collaboratrices et nos
collaborateurs
il faut rendre l'argent ne sont pas
assez payés évidemment non évidemment
alors quand j'entends medef nous dire il
faut baisser le coût du travail et que
ce soit traduit par on va payer des
salaires c'est une folie voilà alors je
me sentant représentée par le medef vous
imaginez bien moi j'en ai besoin du
grand prix de boîtes rapport mais moi je
considère que oui le coût du travail est
trop élevé et nos entreprises sont en
déséquilibre économique à cause de cela
certainement mais en même temps les
salaires nets que nous donnons à nos
jeunes soient notre labeur à 30 ans il
avait collaborateurs sont trop faibles
beaucoup trop faible ils ne permettent
pas de vivre aujourd'hui nous sommes
nous en région parisienne à l'ouest on a
de la chance on est dans un
environnement privilégié aller voir ce
qui se passe dans nord et à l'est et
même le sud et vous allez voir ce qui se
passe et là nous avons un réel problème
sur lesquels les gens sont en train de
se révolter et on entend les reportages
à la télévision à la radio on les lit
dans les journaux les gens d'ailleurs on
leur donne la parole vous vous leur
donnez la parole n'était qu'une bonne
chose ces nouveaux adhérents on les
entendait pas du tout avant maintenant
on commence à entendre des gens
réellement révoltés ils sont révoltés de
valloire il serait votée du fait qu' ils
n'ont pas la récompense normale du
travail dans les campagnes alors que
d'autres lots et de façon bien trop
généreux
attention monsieur mais dès qu il a
raison quand il est les patrons et les
salariés ok mais à condition si vous
fait rentrer un salarié dans le
processus décisionnel français on vous
demande de nous envoyer des gens qui ont
une expérience d'avoir dirigé des hommes
à ce que j'ai vu des députés fermiers
loi sur les hommes sont tous aient la
moindre expérience y ont jamais diriger
des hommes et c'est une catastrophe donc
les salariés oui à condition qu'ils
aient eu des responsabilités comme sur
le voilà sinon c'est après ces dialogues
c'est bien plus dangereux après y'a un
truc sympa la démocratie il ya des gens
évident qu'un salarié aujourd'hui ne se
proposait que par des femmes et des
hommes issus de la collectivité publique
ou des très grandes entreprises
désolé mais aujourd'hui aucun parti
sérieux responsable n'a permis l'entrée
des salariés des nôtres des petites
entreprises dans le monde syndical et
c'est bien dommage
pourquoi pas refaire comme l'app store
jean-michel que vous avez fait des
efforts dans ce domaine et bien
continuer non mais chaque partie oui
quand j'étais député on n'a pas donné
l'investiture parce que j'avais pas les
codes je n'ai pas partie de la maison
j'étais un petit chef d'entreprise etc
même à droite leur père machin c'est au
deuxième tour où ils m'ont donné à
l'investiture pour la première un bon je
m'en souviens un mot pour qu'on passe à
autre un bémol sur le sujet parce que
effectivement j'entends bien le discours
y est je crois que c'est pratiquement
l'engagement de ce four ou sur ses
solides et de promouvoir l'entreprise de
de rendre finalement la parole aux
entrepreneurs bon an mal an qu'ils font
un pays doit être gouverné doit être
organisé alors c'est vrai que les chefs
d'entreprise ont selon cette
caractéristique
simplement on le voit bien tous les
politiques qui venaient de société
civile souvent n'ont pas résisté et pas
forcément réussi donc c'est vrai qu'il
faudrait que les gouvernants fois un peu
ce qui se passe dans l'entreprise mais
l'inversé vrais ceux qui viennent de
l'entreprise doivent quand même se
soucier du bien commun et pas simplement
d'une caisse à gérer comptablement et
qui pourrait amener à d'autres
catastrophes
donc je pense qu'il faut alors aller à
une solution qui draine un équilibre il
arrive par exemple arrêter une à parité
par exemple pour que ça rigolait une
limitation des mandats dans sa serre par
exemple choses ne se soucie pas du bien
commun c'est parce que j'ai tous les
types qui sont j'ai dit salut j'ai de ce
que certains jeux que sont la relation
mais j'ai dix ans alors que mettre la
barre d'un côté il à remettre de l'autre
c'est à dire pas de fonctionnaires
d'ailleurs je note monsieur foreuse que
les trois prétendants au poste suprême
pour ce pays ne sont pas des
entrepreneurs puisque monsieur juppé a
fait l'ena l'ena que je crois vous
voulez supprimer donc juppé a priori
serait pas votre candidat je décris
comprendre tout à l'heure monsieur
sarkozy avocat
monsieur fillion une la politique des
filles ont fait du droit et qui a fait
voilà donc est ce que finalement ils
seraient allés au recours à la
résistance et le mp vous étiez approche
de ce que nicolas sarkozy
bon ça prend pas sa candidature pour
cent des gens qui sont contre rarement
vu dès hier un homme politique dans ce
pays qui est autant aimé par les médias
ou alors qu'on parle autant dans les
humoristes de le taire bon alors je
connais un peu sarkozy d'abord je veux
dire j'ai été impressionné par part
effectivement la lignée rhji et
l'opérationnalité de ce gars je vous
prends un exemple octobre 2008
vous êtes tous se ruiner votre carte
bleue va être avalés par la machine
votre compte d'épargné est nettoyé il ya
un gars qui dirige même bouchain la
table ont accusé moi c'est sarkozy qui
vraiment prendre la situation mondiale
de la crise franchement il est un peu
aidé quand même par son collègue brown
anglais est clairement une scène qui m'a
pas papa qui me kyi qui relate bien
serait-ce que ce qu'est ce que sarkozy
c'est que mon et président de l'europe
et ça c'est un avantage pour moi ce
moment là mais il convoque tous les
chefs d'état et de gouvernement et on
voit une scène où on fait il parla à
merkel d'abord il dit au jambon je
faisais moi fais pas tu es là c'est
sérieux
là c'est sérieux c'est le monde c'est
froid là c'est donc ce qu'ils savent pas
prendre décision ils vont jouer aux
billes
il ya un des pelles et râteaux pour cela
mais il comme ça hein c'est là
maintenant on prend des vraies décisions
alors bon vous êtes prêts là angela la
paire toi
demain matin tu annonce que tu garantie
les banques allemandes pour 700
milliards d'euros je lui fais ça va pas
senna mais cette somme bien ça va pas un
feu nicolas bon et il lui dit angela ton
problème angela sais que tu réfléchis
trop lentement
un délai qui dit quoi ton problème
nicolas c'est que tu réfléchis trop
rapidement et el para el bahr retour à
berlin
elle arrive elle atterrit téléphone son
ministre des finances qu'il n'a pas
accueilli madame la chancelière
c'est grave c'est sarkozy gaz le matin 9
heures elle annonce le déblocage tous
les autres pays aussi suivent derrière
et là vous vous restaurer la confiance
entre les banques et quand l'argent
circule pas où c'est que tout meurt bien
sûr qui était comique ces fonds
et là effectivement on a sauvé le monde
et honnêtement c'est pas pour faire la
pub sarkozy c'est vrai il a joué et même
hollande a même la hollande à l'époque
avait donné le degré de leur connaît
tout le monde reconnaît aujourd'hui à
son bilan est calamiteux il ya des
défauts il agaçant sarkozy c'est vrai il
avait l'air un supporter a pas vraiment
même si les pièces étudiées et efficace
il appelle messieurs et demain parfois
seul 8
trouvez-moi notre capitaine un carnaval
à vous empêcher que le sens le vrai qu
une idée matin son problème c'est qui
encore il a fait une bonne politique ont
été les thèmes de l'europe et puis juste
après ils essayent de mettre son fils à
la tête de l'ehpad
donc il n'a pas vendu si la famille je
ne peux pas mais il a voulu être
candidat c'est le retour de sarkozy vous
y croyez est ce que il ya un sentiment
de revanche on a l'impression pour les
français ne veulent pas le retour parce
que la prime en revanche il est plutôt
de la part de la moitié des deux tiers
des médias qui passent leur temps à
taper sur sarkozy dont il n'est jamais
un type n'a été aussi mais martial et
stipendiés martyr dit y'a pas que c'est
complètement différent d'abord hollande
mais la sarkozie or un bilan comme ça
pas bah oui il n'y avait pas un truc
sarkozy peut faire il sort de chez lui
le matin c'est tout de suite tous les
humoristes se foutent de lui sur toutes
les chaînes nationales
on se moque on se gausse on va chercher
n'importe quoi j'ai dit il ya des gens
qui ne vivent et surtout dans le coup
dans le lot dans l'actuelle majorité qui
ne vivent le matin que pour se dire
qu'est ce que je vais pouvoir dire
contre sarkozy venait on a l'impression
qu'ils ont oublié qu'ils sont là pour
gouverner ce qui devrait s'occuper un
petit peu du gouvernement un petit peu d
affaires et pas de sarkozy j'en ai marre
et j'ai pas d'aller sur nicolas sarkozy
lui-même par contre j'ai un avis parce
que je vis sur le terrain et avec des
gens qui sont en difficulté réelle au
quotidien les français
d'une façon ou d'une autre dans les mois
qui viennent vont renverser la table ça
c'est clair
j'espère que contrairement à notre
habitude culturelle et historique ça se
fera pas dans un van sant voilà mais les
français ont aujourd'hui la plupart dont
la presque totalité donc excepté ceux
qui sont très protégés ils veulent
renverser la table
ils feront confiance demain à celui qui
sera capable de remettre le couvert
convenablement les français veulent pas
le bordel mais il considère que l'état
actuel de leur pays nécessite que la
table soit renversé et donc ils feront
confiance à celui qui saura leur dire
voilà je vais remettre à couvert et ça
va marcher de nouveau nous a laissé un
rameur bon endroit
le peuple s'en moque toutes les
révolutions que nous avons vécu lisez
les ouvrages de jacques marseille dans
ce domaine il est absolument
extraordinaire de précisions il en a
d'autres historiens économistes qui
savent écrire sur ces choses là
regardez ce qu'est la france a vécu dans
ces révolutions successives depuis le
haut moyen-âge et vous vous rendrez
compte que nous ne savons pas faire
autrement que de renverser les tables
hélas la plupart du temps la violence si
nous pouvons éviter cela c'est ce qu'on
craint beaucoup de mes bien entendu
c'est ce qu'on sait c'est que les
proches craignent évidemment donc toute
façon ils vont faire c'est trop tard
maintenant pour revenir en arrière
ils vont le faire j'ai pas comment je
sais pas exactement quand mais c'est en
train de se rapprocher et derrière il
ils font en confiance un homme qui a la
qualité et l'expérience pour
être le couvert donc vous croyez qu'il
faut encore se confier à quelqu'un qui
un exemple de ne pas financièrement
moyens ça on ne peut y venir la solution
c'est bien le vin des dégâts qui va
diriger la france
il doit avoir une qualité d'autres c'est
la capacité de remettre en cause
l'existant ça j'aime beaucoup alain
juppé il m'a marié je suis très ami avec
lui je le connais c'est un inspecteur
des finances
oui mais alain donc on l'a d'ordre à sa
place et c'est bon il n'y a pas de
problème mais mais voilà il alors il a
fait l'ena mais vous avez raison et ça
vous ça vous ça vous marcherez de
charlot avis que de ségou les
subventions alors elle s'est pressée les
voilà et quand ça va devoir les aider
beaucoup le maire aussi en faudrait que
même école aussi mais même moule même
logiciel
normal c'est bien mais on aime bien
esseulé dit j'ai lu sarkozy mois de mai
j'ai vu circuit dans les crises mi
juillet il agace en un mais quel talent
quel talent mais je vous dis passé je ne
bouge pas le choix la bossa mais je vous
dis oui
alors quand on l'accuse des cantons
alors c'est vrai mais c'est
qu'aujourd'hui je voudrais vous soucis
au nom démocratie le pays natif des
droits de l'homme qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça pendant depuis deux ans on est
sur écoute téléphonique
un gars qui est l'un des responsables de
l'opposition dans un pays démocratique
et en même temps pour eux pour pour du
pipeau parce que parce qu'en plus on le
récit du pipeau puisque puisque
puisqu'il ya ya ya ya un non-lieu
ça veut dire ça veut dire ça veut dire
que ça veut dire que pendant deux ans on
l'a on l'a persécutés comme ça sans
preuves réelles
et puis dites moi la convocation à 2
heures du matin non mais moi je veux
bien le petit voyou du coup à jouer avec
moi parce que madame taubira elle est
indépendante n'est pas au courant des
écoutes nommé son directeur de cabinet
du ministre ménard
q les matins bon alors il y avait il ya
peut-être les et coupez les neuf juges
30 policiers pendant deux ans sur le pet
reste et chassait position localisés sur
les haies groupe b derrière les écoutes
ya peut-être des affaires madame taubira
moins de savoir c est ce qu'il est il
vraiment éventail de genres les droits
de l'homme les droits de l'homme les
droits de l'homme
qu'est ce que vous faites pour
récompenser le travail qu'est ce qui
vous fait pour me permettre de décrire
stablement qu'est ce que vous faites
je suis ancien gsm edge et la justice
c'est pas la première respect des droits
de l'homme ans et à la france et aux
français
ces importants tels que seule la couleur
est vitale et droits de l'homme et ayame
sur écoute moi parce que je suis élu là
il y en a qui ne plaît pas la journée
sur écoute vous allez apprécier
sérieuses et pas des élus qui votent sur
écoute c'est la suède qui a décidé c'est
désuet attendu attendez vous êtes naïf
il faut qu'on six candidats sinon leur
dire comment on connaît on connaît
madame taubira tout le monde la connaît
allait devoir en guyane un peu l'image
que leur renvoie la hadopi
soyons sérieux airs franchement monsieur
hollande pourrait voilà remettre la même
taubira dans un autre post
franchement ça a donné un peu d'oxygène
en termes de démocratie de tous à penser
que c'est peut être la france je n'ai
pas noté qui ont été dites et simplement
effectivement les français sont
probablement à bonnaire et probablement
avec l' envie de renverser les tables
problème c'est que quand on les renverse
sous un gouvernement qui est celui ci
probablement qu'on pourrait renverser
sous les prochains et qu'on pourra
aboutir à quelque chose de beaucoup plus
grave
moi j'ai un peu tendance à penser que à
un moment donné il faut un minimum de
stabilité il ya un président qui est là
il est en place alors c'est vrai qu'on
n'est pas forcément d'accord monsieur
fourgous mais on n'était pas forcément
d'accord certains avec le président
sarkozy avant simplement il est
essentiel que des institutions soient
aussi respecter on parlait d'apaisement
tout à l'heure donc on peut en faire
l'écho ici autour de cette table mais on
peut aussi faire passer d'autres
messages qui sont à mon avis beaucoup
plus importants qui sont ceux que un
pays se gouverne aussi avec de
l'apaisement et je pense que nos
institutions le permettent ou à l'ordre
ou alors calmement en changer et à voir
une résonance différentes pour une
parole plus libéré différemment blé
matic c'est que nous sommes dans les
revers depuis des décennies les français
ne sont pas représentés mais donc le
clivage droite droite est complètement
dépassée sais pas si on est à la veille
de deux normalement on va renverser la
table à ce qui serait pas tant c'est une
question que je vous pose qui est une
sorte d'union nationale entre les
républicains que les français si les
communications sur le sait mais
commençons qui veut la présidence je
pense qu'ils savent d'expérience on peut
lui confier vienne l'entreprise en tout
cas la représentativité
la représentante du zoo ou plutôt
l'absence l'absence de représentativité
du peuple dans les différentes instances
et institutions et moi je parle en
qualité de responsable syndical alors je
connais un peu la musique j'y suis
quasiment tous les jours confrontés
l'absence de représentativité du peuple
français dans des conditions normales
pousse aujourd'hui la population à bout
et c'est ce qui probablement déclenchera
de façon très grave le fait que nous
allons aller vers un renversement de la
table alors tu as raison mustapha
j'acquiesce totalement oui il fallait
nous soyons apaisée à condition que
rapidement les français qui aujourd'hui
sont en grave difficulté puissent être
écoutés par quelque intermédiaire le
sont ils pas parler politique
il n'y croit plus pas par les syndicats
il n'y sont pas pas par les chambres de
commerce ou des champions si l'heure il
n'y sont pas non plus donc nous avons un
vrai problème
si ce prêt n'est pas résolue rapidement
nous allons vraiment à la catastrophe
mais ça arrive à la main portant les
codes c'était pour être élu en france
moi je les ai vécus je ne sais pas bien
l'institut re parce que j'ai pas les
codes et et donc du coup bah oui le pop
je n'eus pas je suis suivie d'une
famille modeste je suis né à montreuil
dans les hlm
je travaille la nuit promet du jeu n'est
pas moins qu à l'horaire j'ai repris
mais j'ai passé une équipe du bac pour
reprendre jeudi
j'ai vu la difficulté c'est un monde
cammas est assez fermé est quand même là
où faut bien le dire
et du coup les entrepôts les petits
entrepreneurs comme de c'est vrai qu'on
est pas représentés pour me faire il y
attaquer ce que j'ai ramé et que c'est
l'histoire au deuxième tour j'étais tout
seul
il ya même déjà de vendre un bon et les
17 candidats
on donne et on me donnait 1 % j'étais en
tête au premier tour et là c'est là où
leur père vous téléphone libre écoute et
on voulait vous donner lecture des
premiers tours il viendra au mieux après
le courrier mais bien sûr pour le second
tour bien ça mais je vais adhérer
c'est ça le problème c'est pas pour les
loisirs il ya un problème est un
problème effectivement comme dit
monsieur madec du représentativité et
notamment des gens qui font la richesse
de ce pays qui font les emplois qu'ils
font qui vont garantir les retraites
comment se fait-il que ces gens soient
on leur refuse la présence là ou alors
que c'est eux qu'on est ce que 80% des
solutions sont dans l'entreprise par
dans la fonction publique
il nous reste cinq minutes à peu près on
a deux sujets abordés et vous préférez
quoi les rythmes scolaires où la grève
des pharmaciens dont je les prends en
direct alors je comprends bien que alors
y avoir d'ailleurs une journée le 8
octobre prochain dès des enseignants qui
vont se réunir entre eux donc ça va être
encore à vous de prendre en charge les
enfants pauvres cette journée je
comprends bien que ça soit compliqué
pour les pour les municipalités
tout le monde peut le comprendre mais
est ce que quand il ya 30 % d'échec
scolaire en france qui aurait pas
d'autres débats faire que celui des
rythmes scolaires est de savoir qu'ici
c'est les mairies ou 6 x ou y qui va
s'occuper des enfants
mais ça c'est normal dira qu' on y 25e à
la halle au classement international
bizarre voilà faut faire quelque chose
mais moi j'ai fait deux missions
parlementaires a écrit deux bouquins sur
les sur les sur l'école j'ai quand même
d une la ville qui est quand même
reconnu comme un modèle en france un
jour apple soit pro ou un bon mais et
c'est vrai bon on est visité par
shanghai nord et du sud la russie la
suède exhortons donc les solutions pour
améliorer vraiment ce que les enfants
c'est premièrement de change et de
pédagogie
la pédagogie pas si oui en a qu'un seul
qui parle un et pendant une heure ça
vous rend pas siffler les élèves
cette pédagogie frontale magistral c'est
fini or horizontale terminer un bon
verticale pardon c'est terminé donc
c'est une pédagogie mixe les enfants
apprennent autant l'extérieur de l'école
cac à l'école source la plus numérique
les outils numériques mais c'est une
règle c'est ça l'avenir tous les pays
qui marche bien mais ils vont tous les
temps donc il faut changer cette
pédagogie la rendre beaucoup plus bien
sûr partie va-t-il interactive
deuxièmement former les profs améliorer
leur formation troisièmement changer les
programmes ça voilà vous allez améliorer
le modèle scolaire français part ça on
arrive
faire une réforme des rythmes scolaires
parce que les rythmes scolaires c'est
premièrement 3h30 de cons pour le matin
à 4h30 pour l'élémentaire alors que là
vous en êtes à 5h30 et 6h bon nombre
deuxièmement vous dit deux coupures une
le mercredi et le dimanche
l'enfant ne font pas le couper le week
end est ce qu'après ils apprennent de
synchronisation de joe hill se
désynchronise bon là donc il faut il
faudrait simplement une journée le week
end de séparation et une jaune mercredi
c'est ça à la théorie ça rien à voir
avec ce qu'on propose troisièmement on
vous dit on vous dit il ya un pic de
vigilance chez l'enfant à 15h30
il faut sortir à 15h30 donc elles
respectent même pas la théorie des
deuxièmement ce dernier point on vous
dit faut mieux réparties sur l'année
des heures de course absolument pas le
cas dans tout ça ce n'est pas une infâme
d'être et je suis le plan psychologique
je suis comme je connais un peu le sujet
donc pourquoi on fait dépenser 1
milliard à 2 milliards et milliards sans
contenu sans atelier 5 milliards et 2001
à des contenus est-ce qu'on a les moyens
en ce moment nous enlever 20 % de nos
moyens en deux en amérique on n'a pas
les moyens
il me fait un peu peur quand vous dites
il faut se changer les programmes ce que
je vois par exemple les programmes
d'histoire en ce moment il ya des pans
entiers de l'histoire de france qui ont
disparu alors suivre les hameaux les
anversois c'est ridicule en apprend plus
rond sauver on a conclu riesch d'accord
donc valeur donc allemand dit doucement
sur la refonte des programmes parce que
à force de toujours vouloir tout
bouleversé je viens de level la perte de
l'histoire de france c'est dramatique on
veut pas construire une nation un
sentiment d'appartenance à quoi que ce
soit si peter dixon la france mais là je
pense qu'avant de jack ça marche pas il
faut tester parce que toute façon ce qui
est en place actuellement ne marche pas
voilà la tangente plus fatigué alors les
enfants d'abord il faudrait qu'ils
apprennent à se coucher tôt fac et
parents couchlin enfant plutôt parce que
voilà un enfants dont les deux parents
travaillent
de toute façon ici l'aveu mercredi parce
qu'il veut s'ancrer dans ce qu'il est ce
qu'il sera pas mieux aller à l'école
avec ses copains et tout le monde soit
pareil après les réponses très rapide
ben oui ou des hommes besoin de travail
trop et ben voila j'ai coupon est coupée
gerald avec une enseignante qui m'a dit
que pourquoi pas cette idée de plusieurs
matinées parce que le pays vive de
vigilance il peut être aussi le matin
voilà est allé donnerait plus de temps
aux enfants qui n'ont pas le même rythme
parce qu'il ya toujours des enfants mais
c'est tout marche bien on pourrait leur
faire court et auxquels on ne sait pas
qui on est
pas le débat principal de lancer non
sans avoir dans trois ans si les enfants
qui sort trop fin de cm2 sache ça veut
dire mieux que ceux d'avant et puis
voilà on verra et pourquoi pas tenter ça
quand je trouve ça plus égalitaire que
tout le monde soit à la même sauce les
profs ne crois pas dans cette réforme et
on attend de voir
non mes profs à l'épreuve deux mois
d'épreuves samedi richard abonnés fait
qu'est-ce que les propres eurent
beaucoup de réforme des rythmes
scolaires de trois ans vu que pour le
bonheur des parents peut être pas du
tout pour le bonheur de ses c'est juste
pour que l'ailé des mères et pères
pousse à aller chercher les enfants
c'est uniquement ça donc le bonheur des
enfants tout le monde s'en fout la
profession pharmaceutique est menacée il
serait bon effectivement nous en
parlions pardon c'était une parenthèse
que je reviens mais c'était pour dire
non c'est vrai que sur le sujet c'était
c'était pour une blague mais pour le
coup pour le coup pour le coup c'est
vrai que ce qui me gêne toujours c'est
ça c'est cette idée selon laquelle il ya
une alternance et chacun veut mettre son
empreinte de parme alternance et qu'on
ne laisse pas suffisamment
l'expérimentation après tout on dit que
ça apparemment franchement bien marcher
jusque là les allemands les allemands
les allemands le faisait depuis des
années soit performant voilà donc on va
on va on va tester
il faut laisser un peu de temps au temps
les phares c'est un peu ça mon idée
l'avenir ccpd que droite et gauche
confondues le mans au temps à
l'extérieur de l'école probablement
demain vous savez tout stress que sauf
que monsieur bellamy disait autre chose
est sûre la semaine dernière en disant
que finalement l'informatisation tu es
aussi la culture et la transmission du
savoir comme apprendre 24 quelqu un qui
arrête de l'apprentissage de l'écriture
au moment de passer à leurs noms mais
quand je vois à bondir votre tablette
j'ai un peu peur mais vous savez très
bien que le monde évolue mon le monde
bouge
aujourd'hui grâce à twitter
alors il reste une minute
est ce que vous avez peut-être un coup
de coeur coups de gueule quand on
l'ouvré parler pour conclure cette
émission syndiquée sauf à moi j'ai
appris qu'à pour les patients et les
pharmaciens bien sûr ils rendent un
service mais incroyable à la population
est très fort mais leur promotion
maintenant il faut les laisser gagner
leur argent parce qu'ils le méritent ils
le paient cher ce sont des cellules et
d'autre le cours dans toutes les rues
ils font le psy ils font le médecin de
secours
il évite des consultations chez les
généralistes parce que ils savent dire
mais vous inquiétez pas madame mettez un
pansement c est beaucoup mieux vendu 1
jean michel fourgous et des aigus cette
grève de mardi
en réalité ces mesures sur celles qui
étaient inspirés par le rapport attali
qui resté lettre morte quand il était
remis à nicolas sarkozy le dit et il a
fait beaucoup de choses m'ont fait il ya
des choses aussi qu'il a laissée de côté
ouais mais je vous souhaite de vous
taper la crise avait d'ailleurs envoyé
la guerre froide mais s'effondre à moins
4 cette année c'est grave ce qu'il veut
c'est difficile de juger aussi là dessus
sur tout simplement parce qu'il a cédé
votre nom mais bon c'est ces mesures de
toutes ces mesures ne seraient pas à
prendre si on savait s'il y avait des
compétences pour créer de la richesse
dans ce pays ce pays béni des dieux il
est tout pour lui tout pour demain être
à deux trois ou quatre pour cent de
toute façon il faut niekerk croissance
de + 3 % pour rembourser aux 2000
milliards de dettes et pour sentir le
pays et là où il est il me disait
d'intérêt tous apprendre ce que c'est
que de la croissance et du travail un
but de l'intelligence et du capital ça
va les chercher là haut et demain on
aura plus ce problème et les formations
on n'arrête pas de resserrer le j'avais
un top c'est le mot fidélité est gelée
je dédie au couple jeu des chirac qui
ont chacun leur définition de la
fidélité voilà l'un sarkozy l'autre
donc pas si mal que ça mon peuple de vol
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup jean
michel cros goze merci à tous on se
retrouve du sud quinzaine de jours